everything you see here is handmade only
thing that you see that is not being
made here as the lights the tires and
the glasses and the stereo inside the
rest are all made right here
from my personal experience er it was
like a dream come true
because mostly everything I would want
his work out there coming up with this
new unity was this the first of its kind
in Africa my team and I were actually
very enthused about being part of the
program so personally it's one of my
biggest fulfil
if we have enough funding and we are
important a lot of times we are
manufacturing a lot from here we can
make it possible that every average
Connie and GU Antony salary can be able
to purchase it